bueno podrían pedir asilo
una visa humanitaria no para pedir asilo
como refugiados y habría casos Pues
según el sistema seca el sistema europeo
común de asilo y está también pues la
convención del estatuto para el estatuto
de refugiados de las Naciones Unidas que
bueno podrían ampararles pero claro
depende de cada caso también
Probablemente van a examinar caso por
caso porque no tengo la menor duda que
la inmensa mayoría de esos miles de
rusos que están huyendo son Pues gente
que no quiere morir en el campo de
batalla en Ucrania pero no hay que
descartar que algunos sean enviados
deliberadamente en ese flujo de gente
por el kremlin como agente saboteadores
de inteligencia de la inteligencia
militar como del servicio inteligencia
exterior ruso para en la guerra que se
parece que se avecina entre la otan y
Rusia una tercera guerra mundial lleven
a cabo misiones inteligencias
estratégica y de Sabotaje pero repito
sería una minoría algo así como cuando
se ha dicho que maduro presidente de
Venezuela pues abierto las cárceles para
que preside diarios vayan como
inmigrantes indocumentados a Estados
Unidos o en el caso de Mariel cuando
Fidel Castro abrió pues las cárceles y
envió a las prostitutas y otros
criminales a Estados Unidos entre los
miles y miles de refugiados cubanos que
buscaban libertad Pero hay hay hay hay
una base legal que ampararía a esos
rusos que saben que si van a Ucrania los
puede matar y les pueden obligar a
cometer crímenes de guerra bien
documentados ya que podrían pedir asilo
legítimamente como refugiados
en otros temas Putin oficializó la
anexión de cuatro regiones ucranianas
entre ellas a polilla donde se encuentra
la central nuclear más grande de Europa
qué va a pasar entonces con el trabajo
del organismo internacional de energía
atómica allí en medio de las
preocupaciones sobre un eventual
desastre radioactivo Bueno ahí está la
situación pues incluso sin anexión
dependía de la voluntad de la buena
voluntad entre comillas de los rusos de
Putin sobre su labor allí y si Putin
considera que ya la labor de ellos está
terminada porque eso es solo ruso según
su punto de vista Pues podría
expulsarlos y hacer los rusos lo que
quieran Pues con esa estación pero claro
no hay que olvidar otro contexto el de
la guerra en que Ucrania quiere liberar
esos territorios y la central está
digamos que casi en la línea del frente
para básicamente
mientras el doctor layosas y analista de
relaciones internacionales y estudios
estratégicos de fuerzas terrestres
navales aéreas y espaciales rusas
Gracias por acompañarnos en las 24